to give a talk on science and inside of
AG research in Python which at least
some of you who decided that's an
interesting topic so thank you for
hanging out and so and I also looked at
my timing and saw that I had 40 minutes
and everyone know time everyone's been
taught by Ted that you you're only
supposed to talk for 18 minutes or
people go to sleep so what I've done is
I've except to talk smash together so so
we can change topics so you'll stay stay
involved okay but I'll get to that so I
went talk a little bit about decide to
Python and like the how the coming up
some of the issues like the challenges
and successes of Python and the
scientific community but I also want to
talk about you know going forward as a
community and what are the challenges
that bind us as a community that we have
to face going forward to keep the
community alive and well I realized that
I did have a slide that showed Lea and
James so I so Li and James are in the
back here I went first a big THANK YOU
to Lea and James there they are the ones
who make sure that these pythons are
these PI data conferences actually
happened so let's go around applause
without these two fine folks like none
of these conferences would happen like
clockwork and we really appreciate that
um so first about me so Eddie Carol I'm
chief chief science officer at consume
analytics and also I'm president of
gnome focus which means I get to give a
talk and send a lot of email and code
some but not as much as I'd like my
background comes from high performance
computing and kind of worked with math
computational mathematics and Finance in
different simulations and things like
that do you make that a little more real
of the kind of problems I've always
solved in academia have always looked
like this where you have some math
equations for example here we take the
Euler equations which is that the fluid
kind of the the basic of modern
compressible fluid dynamics
incompressible dynamic and typically
take those
equations which is a great abstraction
but very hard to like really communicate
with the entire population of the world
so that sort of thing well it works
really well for a technical audience
we've had lots of training we often have
to turn that into something one to the
computer can understand and to that
other people can understand so that we
can solve real problems and so you go
over the two axes there I'll work with
for example visualizations and this is
in this case is a to a 1d simulation of
surface of water at a gage height and
supercomputers and working on very
massive computers to make sure that you
can take that 1d problem with scale it
up to a real 2d problem in this case it
solve like it's kind of hard to picture
to see but down here on the bottom right
is solving for example a hurricane sterk
storm surge which has a massive effect
on everybody's life and so going from
that very technical problem to the
stages to actually have actionable
insights to help the government or
businesses make and make determine their
paths such as do I actually put my house
on out on Long Island for example which
is a real problem people have so that's
kind of like you know my academic life
and where the research came from now I
big data kind of happened and they have
the same similar sorts of problems and I
often work now in a different often in a
little bit pivoted workflow where I'm
taking unstructured data and taking data
off of the open web or open like the big
data lose people just having a huge
massive problem just handling all these
things and the same thing going to
algorithms for example machine learning
algorithms where they have the
scikit-learn decision algorithms there
and also for example much smaller
computers these days used to work on
16,000 cores now I get a hundred and
they look they look like this in
comparison I actually googled Hadoop
supercomputer and that's the picture I
got so raspberry PI's so they they
really focus on scale out technologies
and not very
to scale-up technologies and whereas in
previous life you had to have both or
else you were dead in the water and then
finally a lot of these the Peter
mentioned some of the DARPA work we've
done and in this same kind of way making
business decisions although for the
Department of Justice on helping find
human victim and trafficking victims and
things like that and so data science has
a lot of potential in pretty much every
facet of our lives and so I kind of go
through some of it more like the path
that takes that research into actual
production actual getting things done um
so Peter talked a lot about his Venn
diagram and I and so in lieu of the
competing Venn diagrams I pulled out
through Conway's and so I I like to talk
about data science so this is data
science but also computational math is a
very similar where you have some hacking
skills we have the ability to actually
get things done on a computer you have
math and knowledge so being able to do
real abstract thinking about what's
actually going on in your computer and
being able to communicate it with each
other and develop interface and
abstraction as well and then I think the
one thing that a lot of people miss is
like actually doing some standard
expertise so you can have acting skills
and math and that's kind of machine
learning if you don't have that a
substantial expertise of actually
solving real-world problems and coming
and getting them that messiness of data
and things like that that's going data
science in my mind becomes really a lot
of fun but also kind of a moment where
you can really make a big impact on on
society as a whole
but of course we also have a we know
everybody knows those guys who are in
this quote danger zone over here who
have lots of expertise no math
background and just code and those guys
are fun I do like to call it danger I
like to call it fun but so in this kind
of rant realm of like actually getting
together as a community to build these
things out we started this foundation
called um focus and now focus
essentially came from a group of a group
of scientists who were working together
who were sprinting spreading out other
companies already and actually looking
at hey all these companies all this
government all these
government projects and academics are
using our code but nobody's really there
to like build the base and make sure
that it continues in a substantial way
and so none focus has that one simple
goal it's a sustained open science
through open code in that goal so that
everybody for businesses and academics
and everybody can play in this high data
ecosystem and we've expanded to Julia
and R as well so that we actually give
data science at home that's actually
supported and can continue throughout
the future if you go to our website
you'll see this nice banner where we
have kind of breaks down come of our
activities from projects and they'll
show you a list of projects in a second
it's an education such as our like John
Hunter technical fellowship or in our
women and program women in technology
programs we have a very strong desire to
make sure that we have a diverse
ecosystem of contributors in our our
systems fiscal sponsorship for all you
guys who this is Dallas there's a plenty
of money right so uh okay so all you
guys who have want to help us sponsor
these projects and help projects who
need money to actually work and get
their features out and things like that
we definitely help a lot of open source
projects connect with people who can
sponsor them and also pie data which we
were all at here today here's a list
here's a kind of a list of the projects
we kind of touch on from a lot of us
start in a Python world but we have our
open side for example and Julia the next
greatest prize the next greatest data
science language as soon as you know
just don't you don't switch but you can
use them together which is pretty nice
and then also from education so like for
example our insight blog posts or data
carpentry and software carpentry to help
educate the next leaders and data
science and so on here's a list of
people you go to our foundation page you
can see all their names academics
well-known for example the ipython team
Brian and Fernando and then active
people in government government labs and
companies and so on and so forth so a
real kind of mix of folks to help build
this foundation okay so that's kind of
intro and kind of pitch of who we are
why I'm here and what I'm
you know we're so you kind of know who I
am so I want to kind of start by talking
about you know researchers using Python
where did it start why are we sure you
can use Python what are the kind of
major modes that kind of start kind of
give us into this language um for me it
started with this book by Hon Frederick
lunch engine and on this you can't
really see the slide the picture to the
book at all but is a book was called
Python scripting for computational
science and essentially it was Python
for Fortran compiler for train riders
and I mean it was amazing because like
it was way before not numpy existed and
it was this idea that you could have a
single program that would call your
Fortran and your new plot and everything
would just like automatically work and
you can make it hit supercomputers and
all sorts of fancy stuff and this like
it kind of blew my mind a little bit
because at the same time I was you know
struggling with getting all my codes to
even work much less give them to do the
entire cycle in one script so hans-peter
kind of identified a lot of kind of
different ways to use Python in the
scientific workflow and I kind of kind
of broke them down and in my viewpoint
is that there's kind of different
modalities inside like Python in the
research world such as you know first of
all there's kind of Python is a
programming language and doing helping
people become better at their job as as
a better programming language does the
second kind of attack I was like it's
it's kind of glue some people call it
super glue and so a script live people
called scripting language scripting
language is kind of a pejorative term in
the programming language world meaning
it's not a real programming language but
it's something you just kind of do off
the side but at the same time we know
that Python can do a lot of real work
and it does it runs some of the biggest
corporations the world and run some of
the most innovative labs in the world
and so but at the same time the fact
that it can talk to everybody the fact
they can get objects from Java or from C
and actually make them cooperate to the
other there's a really important process
another kind of modality is like is the
delivery of like very complicated
analytics engines every time I see
somebody get up and talk about the dupa
show me worried
word-count a part of me dies because we
Python has such a great ecosystem of
libraries repeat you know people have
come together to find so but really
complicated math to solve these problems
into the ecosystem and Python really
does a really good job of helping them
put that together and deliver it for it
question yes yeah I will and I'll go
through them in just a minute but so
yeah I have I have plenty of examples
yep oh and finally kind of near and dear
to my heart is python is a really good
domain-specific language so you can
really embed a lot of knowledge into the
IMP I thought to give it a deeper
interaction with domain so first off so
I'll go through these various modalities
for some case studies and then next side
of the talk I'll talk about some of the
challenges we have in the community so
the first kind of is can't how can the
programming language help your job I
think I hear this a lot from researchers
because a lot of researchers still will
use oh for trans fast and it does my
complex my complex analysis well or
MATLAB is good enough for me and I don't
have to worry about handling any of that
open source stuff or I hear for example
no I need Java because it's got all this
help this type safety and things like
that and so like this whole idea of like
how does a programming program language
actually help you do your job rather
than you just programming on the
language I think that the one thing I
don't have a lot of examples here but
the one thing I will say about Python
for a researcher is it doesn't get in
your way you can write a Python script
very quickly and do a lot of things in a
very short amount of time but also drive
very complicated things at the same time
so in some sense my view is like get the
programming language out of my way as
quick as possible but also let me kind
of describe what I need done at the same
time and I think the other thing so like
Kim Kennedy at University of Houston had
this or I know here's a rice I'm sorry
thank you it's Molly yeah
it's like 20 miles but can't get rice
had this concept of a telescoping
language and like he chased this program
for a very long time of developing
languages that you could write at one
level a very high level such as like
Java or something that you could
describe okay so he was a Fortran
compiler so Java is way high level to
him so or down to the very low level
which is assembly or something and being
able to take touch points in between it
Python as a language is able to do that
very well where you write Python a very
high level and there's many different
ways to get down to that very low level
programming to get those complex engines
working such as working with scythe on
to go to C or PI ASM if you want to
generate just assembly code or the PI PJ
if you want to drive large Java programs
and things like that so Python actually
as a language it does both the glue but
it also does lowering it down to the
door the bare metal and I realize now
that should have shown Kim Kennedy's big
slide on that but it's a it's a very
important concept but that that being
said I like to solve big problems so I
want to show you guys a little bit about
how you build a flexible system for
solving very complex analytics and I
think one thing about science it's
different from business is that the
appetite for just changing out your
analytics very quickly at least not at
least in your ear researchers day-to-day
and then moving to an operational
day-to-day I think the businesses have
the same idea that they want to drive
innovation but then they want to build
an operational process so there's a
question earlier about how do we deal
with the fact that everything's changing
but in science very often you want
things to change because that's how you
get to better processes so the first
example I have is this code called
piloff is built by usgs that i had some
hand in helping a very minor hand but
it's a it's an earthquake simulator and
so it's a very typical problem that you
have in science where i have some in
this case i have i have to have some
domain i have a point of interest in
that domain that has a lot of activity
that has an effect throughout the rest
of the main in this case it's a fracture
right so the earth fractures
and there's a lot of stress right in
that middle that's with a nice red part
there is it like where the maximum
stress is and then you want to see how
this affects the rest of the ecosystem
in this case the earth and see if it how
many buildings it knocks down or
something like that but the thing there
is that it's not a single problem and
the real the real cause of the problem
is this dynamic rupture but really what
actually affects everybody is this like
what we call quasi static resolutely
relaxation so the fact that this
pressure is gonna be released throughout
the earth and that's actually what's
gonna knock down your buildings or cause
a lot of earthquake damage and so on and
so forth and so even so so even being
able a couple these systems is a very
difficult thing to do because the those
are two very different types of physical
characteristics and so you have multiple
models you have different ways of I have
multiple measures we that's basically
different ways of cutting this problem
with slicing it and figuring out which
part do I solve first and how do I make
that work and then also it has to be
parallel and these are big problems they
have to be highly coupled and so it's
it's a very challenging problem I'll
give you a quick example of that
flexibility one thing we looked at is
like how do we generate how do we couple
all these systems but for example
there's this kind of let's call it a
heated discussion which is a nice
academic way of saying dragged down
knockout fight over whether you should
you try angular's or rectangles like how
stupid is that but the mathematics
around it becomes like just volumes have
been published on this issue so what we
did is create a Python code that
actually tested because we were retired
of getting on these academic fights we
just like you know what we're just gonna
we're gonna write a code that actually
lets us implement what you know very
high-level che I want to triangle or I
want to rectangle but and since we built
a system that kind of handled both both
mathematics and the domain decomposition
well it actually was very flexible and
interoperable and Python allows you to
you know lets the scientists just write
triangle or a rectangle but what he's
really driving is a much larger
architecture that looks like this where
but that applicant that top application
layer
he might say I want a rectangle it pipes
to a symbolic engine my favorite ones
senpai I did have some help writing help
some folks write that we have one of the
core authors here in the audience here
and so we pipe off to the symbolic it
actually takes those equations and now
substitute all the rules of all right
you have triangles here's what your
basic functions looks like oh you have
quite rectangles this is what your basis
function looks like so it comes back and
gives me math but then I can pass off to
a linear solver and also build out the
data structures so those a rectangle
looks a lot different from a triangle
and the data structures in order to
interact with them actually change quite
a bit and then from that go to a linear
solver so pet sees my favorite linear
solver and we then we passed up so
that'll solve the big large equations
but numpy comes back as the data
structure to pass to that application
that they can actually do the
visualization on or the other systems on
so numpy becomes a really nice vehicle
for going from that parallel intent
solver to something that the application
can use and then we also have other
processes that we can use for example
Pike udon and use on a GPU or something
like that and so this kind of notion of
an application touching all these
different pieces and these are all large
codes I think every one of the codes up
here is probably at least I think simp
eyes-only like 30,000 lines but I think
the rest one was like at least a hundred
thousand four hundred thousand writes
type the type codes and so these codes
are very large codes of it since they
interoperate with Python the application
doesn't have to care so much about all
the details and the Python language
takes care of a lot of us those things
so this is an example of doing in the
research world of touching all these
things but you can also do interesting
parts like for that equation definition
that can actually change out my
equations into a different form so
mathematicians can play and get a
different formulation of those equations
and then linear algebra can play because
they can tell give us different ways to
solve linear algebra in the pet/ct and
things like that so it becomes a way
that not only are we leveraging pythons
ability of glue but we're leveraging the
expertise of many different communities
so that's great
but how about a real-world application
because the application I showed wasn't
so it's sort of real world
but it's still just boxes and whatnot so
other turtles are working with the Geo
community I mean what they do is one of
their big applications is predicting
tsunamis and the way they kind of handle
this is that they have grids all over
the although they hit a grid all over
the ocean so when you have a tsunami
event they can track the watt the shock
to the water through throughout the
world and this is an example of the
Chilean tsunami and here like the the
grids the the actual Oh big open grids
are actually refined much lower but if
we show the grid you wouldn't be able to
see the the actual effect so this is a
very real world event that could then be
helped use to predict the surge water
and the way this guy was built and it's
a very old code and so if in here you
have oh we can't see colors at all on
that screen okay but you up here on the
top right you have the cloth hat kernels
and the claw pack kernels is a code from
the 70s I mean 80s I guess depends on
exactly when you count whether it was
written in grad school or not but but
written by Randy Levesque in Fortran the
very old style is like all the books
teach dynamic shocks out of his book so
you have these kernels but now we want
to scale it up to the machines of today
and the way we do that is through this
Python layer where we can talk to this
whole Fortran library and once again
pass off to my favorite linear algebra
library petsy and pepe actually then
talk to the machine so then python well
it doesn't have to be the driver of your
of your analytic data analytics it can
certainly be the driver of something
else that's a big data system or a
parallel system and so on and so forth
and so that's another kind of example
out in the wild where the pike law and
GOP law communities and kind of my final
example well I guess I have two more
examples well another example is what
about capturing that beauty that
mathematics so another project that I
worked on at grad school it's called the
Phoenix project and what they kind of
came to conclusion that they were people
mathematicians who solve a lot
would formulate lots of mathematical
equations so everyone like to ever like
to talk about the the old joke if you
have an engineer and you ask him oh boy
water they'll still give him water in a
pan and though they'll put bullet on the
pan and stick it on the stove and turn
it on and let it boil then a
mathematician comes in because they say
all right boil water and he's like well
here's a pan of water thereby reduction
reduced it to a previously known problem
and give it to the engineer Tommy don't
worry so the same thing happiness
project we have all these mathematicians
with they've proposed lots of ways to
solve these problems for example here's
a heart with lots of mechanics that go
into the defining the how the mains
happen in the heart and which actually
equations to use the heart to funny one
because it doesn't make sense that you
turn off blood flow and then electricity
turns off so it's like somehow it's like
it would be like you turn off your your
your faucet and all of a sudden lights
go out
and so there's a really interesting
coupling going on in the heart and so
like it's it's boggled the mind of
researchers for many years and
mathematicians have lots of models for
doing it but there's not very many ways
to actually get those into code so if I
have 50 models and I I'm the guy with
the code um I usually pick one and if I
get that done in a year I'm good
so they wanted to come out and look at
how do we get this at activity and error
control and they chose Python and so it
typically works like this so this is the
hello world of PDEs
it's called the laplacian and you
basically it that's the mathematical
equation this is how you would find it
in math is like this Delta Delta u
equals up on some domain and most people
be like what it wasn't even mean now
under under the hood what would actually
typically happens you to find some form
and you'd have to come get some compiler
or something to change out of the code
and then you'd have to assemble it and
solve it and do all these sorts of
things well in Python this became a very
easy problem or we just defined our
element and we gave these these
functions and whatnot but then so the
you see this first part we're defining
the types like a func of what the
functions are as the trial and test it
doesn't really matter what they are but
just to know that there's special
functions but in the next part is
something a mathematic mathematician
could read
it's this dot grad x DX which is
actually the same thing that that Delta
U is saying and so immediately we were
able to give us two mathematicians who
were able to then take it and do all
sorts of much fancier things and
eventually get to the heart the heart
simulations and so on and so forth and
just that that inserting of the
domain-specific language a little bit
and Python you can totally take over
like the syntax of the language it's
it's it's sick the number of things you
can do there but it's also fun
remember danger equals fun but it's just
definitely a case it's driving
innovation in the research space so
that's kind of my 30 samples from kind
of the research world what does this
mean for pi data so now as you've
noticed I've switched over much more to
the the data analytics world and if you
look at the data analytics world this is
a nice slide that Christine Doig who's
in the audience somewhere put together
for me and it's it shows kind of like
what's happened in the kind of like the
ecosystem we have like scientific
computing that's been solving a lot of
these big data problems for a long time
we have machine learning that
mathematicians are starting to play
around with data while doing it for a
while but they've started to get really
serious about large amounts of data and
and real computation and so they're
using the scientific computing tools but
then you have the business we're all
over on the other side that they have
distributed full-time distributed
systems and bi and and database tools
and so they they're gonna hit the real
world with these things like there's
their sequel queries or they're there
they're massive amounts of data they've
pulled out of some customer customers
engine and they want to dump into some
place to actually work with this and so
you have this complicated interaction
between you know the actual complex
analytics and the the analysts who are
on the ground gathering data and also
trying to make sense out of all this
data and so we do what I've done in many
times is come in and insert a Python
layer to talk to these very complicated
systems in many ways we call it blaze
it's a blaze is kind of a way to talk to
all different parts of this and manage
the communications and pi
on in a way that can then make use of
those systems and I like architecture
diagram so this is another bad
architecture diagram so the way we kind
of handle that is we have an API for
example the pandas API and the R as an
API are both really good API is that a
lot of people have learned and can can
drive a lot of analytics but in that we
actually grab the the code and turn it
into deferred expression so now I'm not
going straight to my system and
expecting the programmer to understand
that you can't just you know run a
massive solve on the system and expect
it to be fast it would be better if you
filtered down before or or all the kind
of the complexes that go into matching
the both the API to the data and we have
a layer in there so we can actually have
a different compiler an interpreter that
will grab your expression and get the
best code to your exact system that
you're using and then on the far right
is actually what we really care about is
just the data in the computer and time
and time it shows again that you can
give people that data and compute layer
but unless you teach them the principles
of scientific of computing and in
mathematics they often will create big
hair balls so by putting a few api's and
making it so that they don't have to
worry about that changing ecosystem the
weather using spark today or hadoop
today or disco or some other program
other thing we can actually make the
same api talk to many systems and so
that's kind of like part of the
evolution of like doing the research
world and now blaze is kind of coming
online it has a lot of a lot of users
especially in the academic world just
because it gives that that same flavor
that super glue and that complex
interactions inside the ecosystem so on
the research world I spelled his name
wrong but here's some academics that
like I draw a lot of my inspiration from
from Burnett from physicists to computer
scientists mechanical engineers and
mathematics grab my slides later go
check out their blogs they're awesome
but which kind of brings me to the end
of my first peel on Python on research
so any questions on that first too long
ranting talk awesome cool alright so the
next next thing I want to talk about a
little bit is now we had you know we
have a huge ecosystem and we have a lot
of people who are contributing to our
ecosystem and building on and so there's
a few challenges that we've kind of
faced in the none focus is kind of
trying to help address in different ways
and those those challenges I just want
to talk about these three challenges and
kind of give some ponder some thoughts
on think ways we can help keep this
innovation of Python alive and the
Python data ecosystem the first
challenge is keeping code alive what
happens when you don't maintain code
does anyway no rots that's right it
entropy good one you know bit rot for
example if this I like to compare it to
a house so I so you can't see these
projectors so this is a house that's
falling down in the middle of a jungle
I enjoyed one of my researchers got into
one of my friends was researcher got
into an argument with his his boss about
whether you need software he's like like
isn't the software done he's like well
are you done eating it's also you know
it's like maintaining your house it's
like my weekends used to be coding now
it's mowing lawns and chasing rats out
of my at my shed and things like that
and so the same sort of thing happens
with your code and so the important
thing but the other kind of the
important part of this is that software
really is an expression of the people
who build it and where are those people
going and what are they doing and at
least in the research world there's kind
of four main major areas that the code
gets built and you can't see it on this
this here very well but and the top I
have the Department of Energy and
Department energy funds a lot of complex
scientific codes a lot of like a lot of
the bread and butter of like lapak which
it runs all your recommendation engines
and arounds all your linear algebra
routine so
written at the Department of Energy then
there's instruments like the top right I
have the nice telescope in Chile where
you can you can if you're an
astrophysicist is like the the nice
place to go and and have great views but
you are quite lonely because they have
to put these out way away from people
who spread too much light and so but
these guys they need software to run
these huge systems and a good a good
advocate for this is the as Joshua Blum
who has gone and used Python to actually
make robot telescopes where since these
things are so far out and they're hard
to maintain it's hard to find staff to
pull these things in they use Python now
to run the entire ship of many of these
telescopes and so on and so forth but it
like a lot of instruments you look at
CERN you look at Fermilab and so on and
so forth
down on the left is that it's actually a
supercomputing Center I used to work at
and where they employ lots of Sciences
to help people run on big machines
because it's one thing to write code on
your laptop is another thing to write
code that actually works on a parallel
machine at that scale and in an
efficient way and so there's a lot of
people embedded in super reading centers
to help people port their codes so they
can actually solve the real scale the
real sign of problems of scale and then
the last ones XK CDs oh no this is a PhD
comics national postdoc Appreciation
Week and in in academia if you're going
to write code you're kind of you've very
few people get into a professorship
position by writing code nevermind that
that's the thing driving the innovation
and a lot of these a lot of the work
going on today so there's this whole
posters as army of postdocs or science
and research scientists and so on who
working kind of in this underpaid
profession to get things done and
essentially what's happening in almost
every one of these places is that the
staff are realizing that hey I can write
code here or I can join for example the
Google bus and get on the Big Data
bandwagon and keep moving in that and
that that realm and so kind of stop some
of the innovation that happens because
of this the way these structures have
come together now I'm nothing against
goo
they've done a lot for the ecosystem we
have given a lot of back a lot of code
back but it's just kind of natural kind
of I think my friend Vander pause calls
the big big data drink big data brain
during which is fun because he wrote
that blog and then I joined a caddy left
academia it so nice but essentially
what's happening is these coding
projects like everything I talked about
here evolved mathematicians involved
physicists involved engineers and these
people usually come from different
places and they have different legal
structures and makes it very difficult
to collaborate on these projects and if
you go through the traditional academic
routes you're really only gonna see a
very small amount of money get to those
folks the salaries are kind of growing
at companies and everybody can code go
through the code cycle but also the the
fact that these the scientific software
writers leaving it also impacts how much
money actually goes back into the
software and give you kind of a case
study how many people have heard a
Python awesome how many people know like
who develops ipython anyone so who
develops ipython so Fernando that's
that's Fernando and Brian that's one
answer another answer is Microsoft right
Microsoft gives them a lot of money
other answers Berkeley or you see Polly
which are those employers of of these
guys another answer is is something like
this nature so nature kate came in and
and Rackspace Rackspace are doing a lot
of reaks
resources to kind of put things together
so the real answer is a community a very
large community has two leaders at the
point of it and it's become such so
important that magan's like nature have
started publishing their journals and
analytics in it but the team you know as
it's on two continents for academic
institutions and several companies and
so how do you manage this very wide kind
of challenge of people and I think the
other thing they say if it was only
those academic institutions the amount
of money they would see that flows in
would be around 30%
I think that a lot of people are shocked
like how much how little money X so
you'll see big research dollars but chop
that down with 30% that's how much
actually goes to the researchers and so
this kind of this way that we're
building our infrastructure to innovate
is just kind of an old system now my
viewpoint is that the data science
community is a very diverse set of jobs
from that very first kind of slide with
these three three different by Venn
diagrams those are actually it's a
problem because there's a three
different career paths or three
different ways of thinking that's just a
lot of friction but something that is
vital to being solved in so many places
that we're actually moving forward with
it and so if we want to have open code
projects and open gates open communities
we have to manage that complexity and
this is kind of where I know focus was
built we noticed it wasn't really an
institution that's coming along it's
going to solve those problems and so we
created a new one
I think another big problem that people
have is making our codes usable legally
there's a comment on the last talk about
you know we are a heavily regulated
industry how do we make these things
legal and the answer is that well
there's not a single answer there's
definitely opportunities in academia and
there's opportunities in in industry and
this is one place where industry helps a
lot to come in and help manage those
legal entities I think I hear a lot of
people talk to me about Palantir and how
how Palantir is using a sci-fi ecosystem
and making tons of money off the
government because they leak their price
sheet and so on and so forth and so but
my viewpoint is like hey Palantir is
doing a really good job of getting open
source software in the government and
actually supporting the government in
ways that you just couldn't as a grad
student it's my time
five minutes okay so just to share my
story like I started out with the GPL
community the GPL community it was like
really like I don't want the I don't
want companies to make money off my code
and after you know kind of being sat
down and being told well that means that
all these other people can't use your
code and so what I really wanted to
create them think create innovation that
helps the entire world and companies
have a role in
as well as governments as well as
academics so I switched over to the
level man which is the BSD license I
love it little devil man okay but the
BSD license you know it's just kind of
like freedom like that was like GPL was
freedom but it was actually freedom that
made everybody participate in the
freedom the same way
BSD was kind of I don't really care
here's a few rules just I want I want
you to know who who wrote the code and
that works really well for communities
to get together so lowers the barriers
to getting together but there's then
this idea of software patents came up
and being able to protect yourself
against software patents to use open
source codes it became something of an
interesting bottle kind of way of
interacting but though the apache
license has a patent in typification
it's basically the bsd plus a patent
indemnification clause which has done
wonders for their community had an
explosion of kind of the data science
world through through the apache
organization which one reasonably like
so many data science stuff comes out of
the Apache foundation but that's really
in my view the simple problem the big
the much much bigger problem is how you
should execute data so we're going to
have an open base at open code bases at
the so Tico which is this big parsing
library they get they have people inside
companies who donate they actually
donate the bug reports they don't donate
the data because I can't share the data
because data is very tightly held that's
the actual information of your company
but we need some way to share like how
your computer worked how this program
works on your data how where the
bottlenecks what slows things down and
so on and so forth and so data is a huge
problem
it all ends with this last one is
keeping coding or operable there's this
great paper by Kathleen Fisher on this X
700 data description languages most
people didn't even know up one day
description language much less the Nexus
700 so data is the new like my kind of
fuzz layer is that data is the new
operating system we need to make sure
that we can use data in different ways
and make our code can work around that
data and I'll just jump off here so if
you offer a few observations
as research goes for is like making sure
your code process is open to forints
communication being usable and
interoperability is really crucial to
our community to make this community
thrive and get the researchers and the
innovations that they provide involved
in the community so thank you very much
for your time and here's my twitter ID
and my info again thank you very much